Alice: 你还有币吗
Alice: Do you have any coins left?
Lucia: 我还有几个
Lucia: I have a few left.
Alice: 给
Alice: Give it to me.
Lucia: 因为我刚才
Lucia: Because I just
Lucia: 我刚刚一直在那边
Lucia: I was just there.
Alice: 多出来一个
Alice: Got an extra one.
Alice: 那你玩吧
Alice: You play then.
Lucia: 我刚刚一直在
Lucia: I was just
Lucia: 我刚刚那边打了一局那个什么射击
Lucia: I was playing a shooting game over there.
Lucia: 所以很长时间就过去了
Lucia: So a long time passed.
Lucia: 但我只花掉了3个
Lucia: But I only spent three.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈挺好
Alice: Haha, that's great.
Lucia: 有哪个比较好抓的吗
Lucia: Is there an easier one to grab?
Alice: 我觉得都
Alice: I think they all
Alice: 我可能比较笨
Alice: Maybe I'm just clumsy.
Lucia: 还想再抓一次吗
Lucia: Want to try grabbing again?
Lucia: 哈哈不想了
Lucia: Haha, no, I don't want to.
Alice: 啊不想了
Alice: Ah, no, I don't want to.
Lucia: 那我抓了
Lucia: Then I'll grab it.
Lucia: 我找一个
Lucia: I'll find one.
Lucia: 我也不知道哪个好抓
Lucia: I don't even know which one is easy to grab.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 爪子超松的
Alice: The claw is super loose.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 好臭啊
Alice: It smells so bad.
Jake: 会抓吗
Jake: Can you grab it?
Jake: 这个这这是不是很难抓呀
Jake: Is this one very hard to grab?
Tasha: 这种很难抓啊
Tasha: This type is very hard to grab.
Jake: 这个好大好大
Jake: This one is huge.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 他爪子会松
Lucia: The claw will loosen.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 就扎上来之后
Lucia: After it grabs on.
Alice: 给你一点甜头
Alice: It gives you a little sweetness.
Alice: 让你觉得离他近在咫尺
Alice: Makes you feel like it's within reach.
Jake: 对开心一会
Jake: Right, happy for a while.
Jake: 开心个5秒
Jake: Happy for 5 seconds.
Lucia: 那边还有那个开车和射击的游戏
Lucia: Over there, there's driving and shooting games.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我刚去玩了一局射击回来
Lucia: I just played a shooting game.
Jake: 哈哈看看修硕打怎么样了
Jake: Haha, let's see how Shure is doing.
Jake: 过弯了吗哥
Jake: Did you make the turn, bro?
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: Made it, made it.
Jake: 过了
Jake: Made it.
Shure:  换一个换一个吧
Shure: Let's switch, let's switch.
Jake: 可以可以行行
Jake: Okay, okay, sure, sure.
Jake: 摩手是吧
Jake: Rub hands, right?
Jake: 这是我们现在唯一的成果对吧
Jake: This is our only achievement so far, right?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake: 可以还有8个
Jake: We can still get 8 more.
Alice: 三眼仔
Alice: Little green men.
Katrina:  去不去玩那种打打打杀杀的
Katrina: Want to go play those fighting games?
Jake: 还剩4个币
Jake: Only 4 tokens left.
Jake: 再来两局
Tasha: 呃是不是一天要走3个
Jake: 一共三个吧
Jake: Altogether three, right?
Jake: 打一架
Jake: Let's fight.
Tasha: 先来第一架
Tasha: Let's start with the first match.
Tasha: 第二架输的
Tasha: The second match, the loser...
Tasha: 赢的人跟赢的人在玩第二把
Tasha: The winners will play against each other in the second round.
Alice: 啥玩意啊
Alice: What the heck?
Alice: 快点
Alice: Hurry up.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay!
Jake: 啊怎么这么多
Jake: Ah, why so many?
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Jake: 这什么呀这是
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 叮当竹
Alice: Ding-dong bamboo.
Jake: 啊哈哈啊啊啊哈哈
Jake: Ah haha ah ah ah haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Tasha: 开心吗啊
Tasha: Are you happy now?
Tasha: 这下你满意了吗
Tasha: Are you satisfied now?
Alice: 走吧啊
Alice: Let's go, huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:这这
Jake: This, this...
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Alice: 今天出行是不是对首饰不太利啊
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 拿给硕看一下好
Tasha: Show it to Shure, okay?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 啊啊啊哈
Jake: Ah ah ah ha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:看一下
Alice: Take a look.
Jake: 啊哈
Jake: Ah ha.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:给给你
Alice: Here, take it.
Alice: 哎在这在这在这
Alice: Hey, it's here, it's here, it's here.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈你你这个不亮了
Jake: Hahaha, your thing isn't lighting up.
Jake: 你这你这没电了吗
Jake: Is it out of battery?
Tasha: 没电了吧
Tasha: Out of battery?
Tasha: 啊他的心可能碎了啊
Tasha: Ah, his heart might be broken now.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 轻轻的碎了
Alice: It broke gently.
Shure:  还有五五个
Shure: There are fifty-five left.
Shure:  有有人跟我飙一下吗
Shure: Is anyone gonna race with me?
Jake: 飙什么呀
Jake: Race what?
Shure:  标什么呀
Shure: Race what?
Shure:  飙一下这个
Shure: Race this.
Jake: 这个是多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 这么多啊
Jake: That's a lot.
Jake: 感觉凑这边还有两个
Jake: I feel like there are still two more here.
Jake: 谁要跟他标
Jake: Who wants to race with him?
Jake: 五个现在总共凑不出来了
Jake: We can't gather five now.
Alice: 吵死了
Alice: So noisy.
Alice: 你累吗
Alice: Are you tired?
其他人：有点累
Others: A little bit.
Katrina:  给我一个币
Katrina: Give me a coin.
Jake: 一群赛博人进达赛博区域
Jake: A group of cyber people entering the cyber area.
Katrina:  这怎么玩啊
Katrina: How do you play this?
Jake: 会开车吗
Jake: Can you drive?
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 为什么都在拍我呢
Jake: Why is everyone filming me?
Jake: 呵呵干嘛
Jake: Haha, what's up?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place.
Jake: 这这相机是
Jake: This, this camera is...
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 你得到这注册一下还是这个意思是吧
Jake: Do you need to register or something like that?
Jake: 是上车之前拍个照
Jake: Is it taking a photo before getting in the car?
Jake: 然后再上车
Jake: And then get in the car.
Jake: 考驾照啊
Jake: Taking a driving test?
Alice: 你的课多吗
Alice: Do you have a lot of classes?
其他人：还行我的课不太多
Others: Not too many.
其他人：但就是有时候会被导师叫着干活
Others: But sometimes the supervisor asks me to do work.
其他人：什么的像刚刚我在公园走
Others: Like just now, I was walking in the park.
其他人：然后就在微信上突然问我在不在
Others: And then he suddenly asked me on WeChat if I was there.
其他人：吓坏了因为我其实是溜出来的嘛
Others: I was scared because I actually sneaked out.
其他人：然后但是我导
Others: But my supervisor...
其他人：我导师其实在校外讲课
Others: My supervisor was actually teaching outside the school.
其他人：所以他应该也不是在实验室在抓我
Others: So he shouldn't be in the lab catching me.
其他人：所以说我就说呃下一个怎么回事
Others: So I said, uh, what's next?
其他人：然后就让我帮他做问卷什么的
Others: And he asked me to help with a questionnaire or something.
Alice: 我觉得你像小精灵
Alice: I think you look like a little elf.
其他人：是吗哦谢谢
Others: Really? Oh, thank you.
Alice: 就很灵动很自由对
Alice: It's very lively and free, right?
其他人：对
Others: Right.
其他人：我觉得我剪了这个头发之后
Others: I feel like after I cut this hair,
其他人：就更更放的开一点
Others: I became more open.
其他人：对我之前头发特别长
Others: My hair used to be really long.
其他人：而且我我还为了好看
Others: And I used to add hair extensions to look good.
其他人：我会带一些假发片什么的
Others: But now I feel more comfortable.
其他人：但现在就会更舒服
Alice: 就很享受做自己
Alice: Just enjoying being myself.
其他人：对对是的还蛮好的
Others: Yes, yes, it's quite nice.
Alice: 就外在的一些改变
Alice: Some external changes
Alice: 会逐渐改变你心里的状态
Alice: can gradually change your inner state.
Alice: 也会影响心里的状态
Alice: It can also affect your inner state.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Jake: 币用光了吗
Jake: Are the coins all used up?
Jake: 还是还有
Jake: Or is there any left?
Jake: 还有最后一个
Jake: There's one left.
Jake: 还有一个币
Jake: There's one coin left.
Jake: 能干嘛
Jake: What can it do?
Jake: 这个啊这这一个币
Jake: This one, this one coin.
Jake: 我靠呵呵呵
Jake: Oh my, haha.
Alice: 真是一个币
Alice: It really is just one coin.
Jake: 我靠真的
Jake: Oh my, really.
Jake: 好看你表演吧
Jake: Okay, you go perform.
Jake: 路亚那边有几个币他人呢
Jake: How many coins does Lucy have over there? Where is she?
Alice: Lucy呢
Alice: Where's Lucia?
Jake: 找找去啊先
Jake: Go find her first.
Jake: 那你你坐着坐着
Jake: You, you sit down.
Alice: （歌词）我才不在意
Alice: (Lyrics) I don't care.
Alice: （歌词）我在意的是
Alice: (Lyrics) What I care about is...
Jake: 找不到一点
Jake: Can't find it at all.
Alice: 啊在这里
Alice: Ah, here it is.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay!
Alice: 通关
Alice: Passed!
Lucia: 这个也好长时间
Lucia: This took a long time.
Lucia: 我在这玩了好久了
Lucia: I've been playing here for a while.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 还还有币吗
Jake: Are there any coins left?
Lucia: 好像还有几个
Lucia: Seems like there are a few left.
Jake: 还有还有几个呀
Jake: How many more do we have?
Lucia: 还有123 789
Lucia: We have 123, 789.
Jake: 好好多币
Jake: Wow, a lot of coins.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 可以我剩下
Jake: Okay, I have a few left.
Jake: 剩下都只剩一个币了
Jake: Only one coin left.
Jake: OK像这个3币就下去了
Jake: Okay, this one with 3 coins is done.
Jake: 1秒3币就对
Jake: Three coins in one second, right.
Jake: OK对对对对
Jake: Okay, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 你们还要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you want to play anything else?
Jake: 还还得学经济学
Jake: Still need to study economics.
Lucia: 那当然了
Lucia: Of course.
Jake: 这些都是浮云
Jake: These are all insignificant.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 对对这种这种就是成本太高了
Lucia: Yeah, this kind of thing has high costs.
Lucia: 收获太低
Lucia: Low rewards.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 你要玩点啥吗
Lucia: Do you want to play anything?
Lucia: 还有9个
Lucia: We have 9 left.
Alice: 啊我不玩
Alice: Ah, I don't want to play.
Lucia: 咱三个人可以一人玩一局
Lucia: The three of us can each play a round.
Jake: 呵呵确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Alice: （歌词）了有趣
Alice: (Lyrics) It was fun.
Jake: 在晃悠晃悠
Jake: Just wandering around.
Jake: 他们在开车
Jake: They're driving.
Alice:（歌词） 我才不在意
Alice: (Lyrics) I don't care.
Alice: （歌词）我在意的是
Alice: (Lyrics) What I care about is...
Lucia: 你们要开吗
Lucia: Do you want to open it?
Jake: 可以开
Jake: You can open it.
Alice:（歌词） 你的有趣
Alice: (Lyrics) Your fun.
Lucia: 要开吗你开了吗
Lucia: Do you want to open it? Have you opened it?
Alice:我不玩
Alice: I'm not playing.
Jake: 你这有9个币
Jake: You have 9 coins here.
Jake: 那能凑10 哎
Jake: You can make it 10, hey.
Jake: 能凑10个吗
Jake: Can you make it 10?
Lucia: 不开我就去玩跳舞机了
Lucia: If not, I'm going to play the dancing machine.
Lucia: 啊不行这要带那个要带头盔
Lucia: Ah, no, you need to wear a helmet for that.
Shure:  他可以再这个
Shure: He can do it again.
Shure:  因为他赢了
Shure: Because he won.
Shure:  他是不需要再投币子的
Shure: He doesn't need to insert more coins.
Shure:  所以如果想玩的话可以再来一次
Shure: So if you want to play again, we can go for another round.
Shure:  杨老板要试试吗
Shure: Jake, do you want to try?
Jake: 再来一局
Jake: Let's go for another round.
Lucia: 那我跟你再来一局哈哈哈
Lucia: Then I'll play another round with you, haha.
Katrina:  那你俩玩
Katrina: You two play then.
Lucia: 所以啥意思
Lucia: So what does that mean?
Lucia: 是你那边不用投是吧
Lucia: You don't have to vote, right?
Shure:  对应该这边不用投
Shure: Yes, you shouldn't have to vote here.
Jake: 这你还可以续一局是吧
Jake: You can continue for another round, right?
Alice: （歌词）可惜你错过了大雨忍不住的声响你
Alice: (Lyrics) Unfortunately, you missed the sound of the heavy rain you couldn't resist.
Jake: 哦你无论如何都有一局
Jake: Oh, you get one round no matter what.
Jake: 你那个币是怎么花的呀
Jake: How did you spend that coin?
Jake: 还没花了
Jake: Have you spent it yet?
Lucia: 那你投呗
Lucia: Then you should vote.
Alice: （歌词）是你吗还是我
Alice: (Lyrics) Is it you or is it me?
Jake: 可以捐了一毛
Jake: You can donate a dime.
Alice: （歌词）一切
Alice: (Lyrics) Everything.
Alice: （歌词）我的心是你
Alice: (Lyrics) My heart is yours.
Lucia: 然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then do I press start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yes, you press start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left now? None left.
Alice: （歌词）不如落在雨中
Alice: (Lyrics) Better to fall in the rain.
Jake: 确实不剩了应该
Jake: Definitely none left, right?
Alice: （歌词） 为什么要把花放在我脸上相爱
Alice: (Lyrics) Why put flowers on my face and fall in love?
Shure:  你们你们
Shure: You guys, you guys.
Shure:  谁要再来一局
Shure: Who wants to play another round?
Shure:  来来试一试
Shure: Come on, give it a try.
Alice: （歌词）就算我反复复复
Alice: (Lyrics) Even if I keep repeating.
Shure:  还有人要来一局吗
Shure: Anyone else want to play a round?
其他人：我没带眼镜
Others: I didn't bring my glasses.
其他人： 他们玩比较好
Others: They play better.
Alice: 或者你带着我的去玩哇
Alice: Or you can play with mine, wow.
其他人：没事没事这个
Others: It's okay, it's okay, this.
Alice: 其他两个剧组人员都是本科大四的吗
Alice: Are the other two crew members also college seniors?
其他人：对对对是啊我比他们都大一岁
Others: Yes, yes, I am a year older than them.
其他人： 你有做美甲吗
Others: Did you get your nails done?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
其他人： 你也没做美甲
Others: You didn't get your nails done either.
其他人：我也没做
Others: I didn't get mine done either.
Alice: 之前做这个
Alice: I did this before.
其他人：这个还形状还挺好的
Others: This shape is actually pretty good.
Alice: 之前我都抠掉了
Alice: I used to pick it off before.
Alice: 后来就没做
Alice: Then I stopped doing it.
Alice: 感觉闷得慌
Alice: It felt stuffy.
其他人：嗯去了但是我特别喜欢咬指甲
Others: Yeah, but I really like biting my nails.
其他人： 所以我是
Others: So I...
Alice: 你做了之后会咬吗
Alice: Do you still bite them after doing it?
其他人：我没做过
Others: I've never done it.
其他人：我从来没做过
Others: I've never done it at all.
Alice: 哈哈我之前喜欢做
Alice: Haha, I used to like doing it.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
其他人：好热啊
Others: It's so hot.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 你有什么爱好吗
Alice: Do you have any hobbies?
其他人：我平时就画画
Others: I usually just draw.
其他人：其实我很宅的
Others: I'm actually a homebody.
其他人：然后我运动都很差
Others: And I'm really bad at sports.
其他人： 对然后一般就是在家看电影看东西
Others: Yeah, so I usually just stay home, watch movies, and stuff.
其他人：然后画画
Others: And draw.
Alice: 你是一个向内收的人
Alice: You're someone who looks inward.
其他人： 哀人那你呢
Others: And you, what about you?
其他人：你有什么爱好
Others: What hobbies do you have?
Alice: 我都是三分钟热度的爱好
Alice: I usually have short-lived hobbies.
其他人：待会就要去
Others: We're going soon.
Alice: 买菜了
Alice: To buy groceries.
Alice: 今天晚上他们应该不来吧
Alice: They probably won't come tonight, right?
其他人：他们应该不来了
Others: Yeah, they probably won't.
Alice: 你今天晚上要走是吗
Alice: You're leaving tonight, right?
其他人：对我待会五六点就得走了
Others: Yeah, I have to leave around five or six.
其他人：因为我明天在学校还有事
Others: Because I have stuff at school tomorrow.
其他人：所以我得赶回去
Others: So I need to head back.
其他人： 不知道还能不能吃到几口
Others: Not sure if I'll get to eat much.
其他人：因为我5点半休息
Others: Since I get off at 5:30.
其他人： 都得就差不多得
Others: So it's gonna be tight.
Alice: 你可以在我在盒马买一点即食的
Alice: You can grab some ready-to-eat food from Hema.
其他人：可以的然后还可以让他帮我报销
Others: Yeah, and I can get reimbursed for it.
其他人：就是把我的这个东西
Others: Just include it in the group expense.
其他人： 算在大家的那个材料里面
Others: It won't cost anything.
其他人：不花钱的
Others: It's free.
Alice: 河马的一人食我觉得还蛮不错的
Alice: The single-serve meals from Hema are pretty good.
其他人：是吧
Others: Right?
Alice:有个什么牛肝菌拌饭
Alice: There's a porcini mushroom rice dish.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow.
Alice: 然后什么
Alice: And then...
其他人：那个酱好吃我很少去河马
Others: That sauce is delicious. I rarely go to Hema.
其他人：但是我去过一次就觉得花样好多
Others: But the one time I went, I thought there were so many options.
其他人：嗯像一个就比小吃街还丰富那种
Others: Yeah, it's even more diverse than a street food market.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
其他人：还蛮好的
Others: It's pretty good.
Alice: 我暑假的时候
Alice: During the summer vacation...
Alice: 因为我家离盒马比较近嘛
Alice: Because I live pretty close to Hema...
Alice: 然后每天晚上出去散步的时候
Alice: So every evening when I go for a walk...
Alice: 我就走着去盒马
Alice: I walk to Hema.
Alice: 买完之后再回来
Alice: Buy things and then walk back.
其他人：那很好，很爽啊
Alice: 嗯然后有时候能赶上他那个打6折
Alice: And sometimes I catch their 40% off sales.
Alice: 7折八折
Alice: 30% or 20% off.
Alice: 就是快到赏位期的那个嘛
Alice: On items that are about to expire.
Alice: 就晚因为我是晚上去的
Alice: Because I go in the evening.
Alice: 他就很好
Alice: It's really nice.
Alice: 那你是不是也不会去酒吧
Alice: So you don't go to bars either?
Alice: 这种地方
Alice: Places like that.
其他人：我没怎么去过
Others: I rarely go.
其他人：但是我听说像北京优航就是那种
Others: But I've heard places like Beijing Youhang...
其他人：店里如果还有酒我可能会点
Others: If they have alcohol, I might order some.
其他人：但是我不会去酒吧
Others: But I don't go to bars.
其他人：还没去过
Others: Never been.
Alice: 你是不是也不太喜欢特别吵的地方
Alice: You don't like really noisy places, do you?
其他人：对对对是的
Others: Yes, exactly.
Alice: 你饿的话可以先吃这个哦
Alice: If you're hungry, you can eat this.
Alice: 真的呀哦
Alice: Really, oh.
Alice: 你吃吧拿开吧
Alice: Go ahead, take it.
其他人：没事我现在先不吃
Others: It's okay, I'm not eating now.
其他人：我喝的还挺饱的
Others: I'm quite full from drinking.
其他人：我刚渴了
Others: I was thirsty.
其他人： 一下子喝了这么多
Others: So I drank a lot.
其他人：然后我又止不住的喝了这么多
Others: And I couldn't stop drinking more.
其他人：都快喝完了
Others: Almost finished it all.
Alice: 这个糖分比较高
Alice: This has a lot of sugar.
Alice: 所以就等于补充能量了
Alice: So it replenishes energy.
其他人：对啊真的啊
Others: Yeah, really.
其他人： 哈还挺高的
Others: Haha, it's quite high.
其他人：还好还好
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's fine.
其他人：但我真的很喜欢喝饮料
Others: But I really like drinking beverages.
其他人：像各种什么酸奶啊牛奶啊
Others: Like various yogurts and milk.
其他人： 然后这种饮料啊
Others: And these kinds of drinks.
其他人：牛奶饮料我都所有饮料我都很爱喝
Others: Milk drinks, I love all kinds of drinks.
Alice: 那你夏天会自己调果汁
Alice: Do you make your own juice in the summer?
Alice: 调酒那种
Alice: Like cocktails?
Alice: 气泡水那种
Alice: Or sparkling water?
其他人：会啊会啊
Others: Yeah, yeah.
其他人：你会吧会有那种什么
Others: You do, right? Like...
其他人：呃比如旺仔加在茶里面那种
Others: Uh, for example, adding Wangzai milk to tea.
其他人：就很我每次收到我都会保存
Others: Every time I receive it, I save it.
Alice: 感觉像你会
Alice: I feel like you would.
Alice: 就是夏天弄点小冰水的那种类型
Alice: Like making some ice water in the summer.
Alice: 哒哒哒哒哒哒
Alice: Da da da da da da.
其他人：是不是可以走了
Others: Can we leave now?
Alice: 快结束了
Alice: It's almost over.
其他人：他不是在跟他比他自己在比
Others: He's not competing with him, he's competing with himself.
其他人：他在跟电脑比赛是吧
Others: He's competing against the computer, right?
Alice: 可能是吧哈哈哈
Alice: Maybe, haha.
Jake: 好你还有
Jake: Okay, you still have...
Jake: 一次还还可以吗
Jake: One more, is it still okay?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Lucia: 是我就随便按一下
Lucia: If it were me, I'd just press randomly.
Jake: 哎啊没了
Jake: Ah, it's gone.
Shure:  走啊走
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Jake: 收获满满
Jake: Harvesting a lot.
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: Yeah, it's okay, we have something to prove we were here.
Jake: 不然这一段可能就撵不上
Jake: Otherwise, we might not be able to catch up.
Jake: 对对对然后问这哪来的对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, and then they ask where it's from, right.
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There are still three more.
Alice: 还有3个哈哈
Alice: There are three more, haha.
Lucia: 可能因为我一直都在玩那些游戏
Lucia: Maybe because I've been playing those games all the time.
Alice: 好像蛇皮
Alice: Like snake skin.
Lucia: 花的时间很久
Lucia: Spent a lot of time.
Lucia: 这能推下来吗
Lucia: Can this be pushed down?
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's still a bowling ball over there for one dollar.
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone put in two coins earlier.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: Just one more left and we can play.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱这这这这这这
Jake: Then we can make money from money, this this this...
Tasha: 我也想玩节奏大师来着
Tasha: I also want to play Rhythm Master.
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Jake: There was a Buddha before.
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: Yeah, this one is also 2/3.
Jake: 这也是2/3
Jake: This one is also 2/3.
Jake: 来了
Jake: It's here.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yeah, the more centered the better.
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You still have one more chance.
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: You can try hitting to the left.
Tasha: 啊我比你厉害哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I'm better than you, hahaha.
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more off-center, the higher the score, you know.
Shure:  来下一位
Shure: Next player.
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual about this.
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, my hand slipped.
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: There's more, there's more.
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come.
Lucia: 怎么回事啊哈哈哈
Lucia: What's going on, hahaha.
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: It's over, it's over, we're done.
Jake: 好走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: There are two coins left.
Jake: 两个币就钱生钱吧
Jake: Two coins to make more money.
Tasha: 放在哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it?
Lucia: 哦你按他才会释放好像
Lucia: Oh, you have to press it to release it, I think.
Tasha: 好石沉大海
Tasha: Alright, it's like sinking into the sea.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Jake: 在前1秒钟
Jake: In the first second.
Lucia: 然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it and it will drop.
Lucia: 按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press it lightly, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release it.
Lucia: 好像叠住了哈哈
Lucia: It seems to be stacked, haha.
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, hahaha.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 我记得小时候
Lucia: I remember when I was a kid.
Lucia: 这个推币机特别容易掉币
Lucia: This coin pusher used to drop coins easily.
Lucia: 现在好像都把它改造的越来越不容易
Lucia: It seems like they are making it harder and harder.
Lucia: 赢了
Lucia: Won.
Shure:  哎杨老板呢
Shure: Hey, where's Jake?
Katrina:  耶怎么到名创优品奥特曼呢
Katrina: Hey, why are we at MINISO with Ultraman?
Shure:  盒马盒马
Shure: Hema, Hema.
Alice: 芭比
Alice: Barbie.
Alice: 哎你有在西安玩比较多吗
Alice: Hey, do you spend a lot of time in Xi'an?
Alice: 常出门吗
Alice: Do you go out often?
Lucia: 不是很长但如果你说旅游景点的话
Lucia: Not very often, but if you're talking about tourist spots,
Lucia: 也是去过一些的
Lucia: I've been to a few.
Alice: 那你觉得比较好玩的地方是哪里呢
Alice: So, which places do you think are the most fun?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah...
Lucia: 大雁塔
Lucia: The Giant Wild Goose Pagoda.
Alice: 哈哈哈还有呢
Alice: Haha, what else?
Lucia: 还有呢就因为西安的话
Lucia: What else... well, in Xi'an,
Lucia: 就他景点都是那些什么古迹什么的嘛
Lucia: most of the spots are historical sites, right?
Lucia: 如果你喜欢逛博物馆的话
Lucia: If you like visiting museums,
Lucia: 可以去碑林博物馆还有闪丽博
Lucia: you can go to the Beilin Museum or Shannxi History Museum,
Lucia: 还有西安博物馆
Lucia: and the Xi'an Museum.
Lucia: 但是闪丽博好像这两年比较火
Lucia: But the Shannxi History Museum has been popular these past few years,
Lucia: 然后就特别难约票
Lucia: so it's really hard to get tickets.
Lucia: 就要提前几天开始约票才行
Lucia: You have to book tickets a few days in advance.
Lucia: 但是这几个
Lucia: But these,
Lucia: 碑林博物馆好像是要门票的
Lucia: the Beilin Museum requires tickets,
Lucia: 但是闪丽博和西安博物馆都是免费的
Lucia: but the Shannxi History Museum and the Xi'an Museum are free.
Alice: 没事吧没事吧
Alice: Are you okay? Are you okay?
Lucia: 就只要预约就行
Lucia: You just need to make a reservation.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 然后干嘛去
Tasha: So, what now?
Tasha: 哎你看我买帽子的地方
Tasha: Hey, look at where I buy my hats.
Lucia: 这就是那天那个的green party
Lucia: This is from that Green Party the other day.
Lucia: 为什么现在会有这么多室内的
Lucia: Why are there so many indoor
Lucia: 这样的篮球场
Lucia: basketball courts now?
Lucia: 篮球不应该在室外打吗
Lucia: Basketball should be played outdoors, right?
Tasha: 可能帅吧
Tasha: Maybe it's cooler.
Lucia: 哈哈有道理哈哈
Lucia: Haha, makes sense, haha.
Jake: 对是一样
Jake: Yeah, that's true.
Jake: 能室内就室内
Jake: If you can play indoors, why not?
Tasha: 现在干嘛去
Tasha: What now?
Tasha: 怎么人不见了
Tasha: Where did everyone go?
Alice: 盒马哎人呢
Alice: Hey, where is everyone at Hema?
Lucia: 人呢
Lucia: Where is everyone?
Jake: 剩下的人去哪了呢
Jake: Where did the rest of the people go?
Jake: 好走走
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's wander around.
Jake: 嘿嘿公共switch
Jake: Haha, public switch.
Alice: 他们是不是去那个好特卖了
Alice: Did they go to that great sale?
Alice: 闻到了糖浆的味道
Tasha: 哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, turns out they already started shopping.
Jake: 好玩吗有肉吗
Jake: Is it fun? Is there meat?
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a...
Jake: 啥呀这都是
Jake: What's all this?
Lucia: 亚超市
Lucia: An Asian supermarket.
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: Super discount supermarket.
Jake: 噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  杨老板逛过吗
Shure: Have you been here before, Jake?
Jake: 没有那
Jake: No, not here.
Shure:  新加坡有有
Shure: Is there something like this in Singapore?
Shure:  有这种的吗
Shure: Do they have this?
Jake: 3块3的牙刷好有
Jake: 3.3 yuan toothbrushes, yes.
Jake: 好像没有一元
Jake: But I don't think there's a one-yuan store.
Jake:  one dollar那些
Jake: Like those one dollar stores.
Katrina:  袋可以多大呀有小袋没
Katrina: How big can the bags be? Are there small bags?
Katrina:  行吧就这个
Katrina: Okay, let's go with this one.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What are some good and cheap things here?
Lucia: 不知道我也只逛过一次
Lucia: I don't know, I've only been here once.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 3块9的巴黎矿泉水早上
Jake: 3.9 yuan for Perrier water in the morning.
Shure:  画面
Shure: The scene...
Jake: 应该再整点这个对
Jake: We should get some more of this, right?
Lucia: 哦这个这个
Lucia: Oh, this, this.
Lucia: 在这里卖的还挺便宜的嘛
Lucia: It's quite cheap here.
Shure:  为什么啊
Shure: Why?
Shure:  确实 12块5呢
Shure: Indeed, 12.5 yuan.
Lucia: 这在国国内有地方卖老贵
Lucia: It's really expensive in some places in the country.
Jake: 卖老贵
Jake: Really expensive.
Lucia: 呃卖老贵
Lucia: Yeah, really expensive.
Jake: 哦真的呀 12块5
Jake: Oh really? 12.5 yuan.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  星巴克那玻璃那个更贵巴黎水
Shure: The glass one at Starbucks is even more expensive, Perrier.
Lucia: oldly
Lucia: Oldly
Jake: 啊这个些酒是不是也很便宜
Jake: Ah, are these wines also very cheap?
Katrina:  微便宜啊两块钱
Katrina: Kind of cheap, two bucks.
Shure:  啊确实
Shure: Ah, indeed.
Katrina:  次我们学校对面有好特卖
Katrina: Next to our school, there's a good sale.
Katrina:  每次下课就来逛好特卖
Katrina: I go to check it out after every class.
Shure:  这个气泡酒
Shure: This sparkling wine.
其他人：我也想买一瓶
Others: I want to buy a bottle too.
Alice: 明治的
Alice: Meiji's.
Lucia: 对但是当
Lucia: Yes, but also.
Lucia: 当然也要看你
Lucia: Of course, you have to see.
Lucia: 就是本身葡萄的质量怎么样
Lucia: The quality of the grapes themselves.
Lucia: 但是就是莫斯卡托应该是产地
Lucia: But Moscato should be about the origin.
Shure:  不是有效 2033年
Shure: It's not valid until 2033.
Shure:  今天晚上蹦一下好吧
Shure: Let's party tonight, alright?
Jake: 我们好啊
Jake: Sounds good to us.
Jake: 今晚能蹦吗
Jake: Can we party tonight?
Katrina:  啊但是不想买
Katrina: Ah, but I don't want to buy it.
Katrina:  强爽了没有
Katrina: Is there no strong one?
Alice: 普通的还是强爽
Alice: Regular or strong?
Katrina:  没找到普通的
Katrina: Couldn't find the regular one.
Katrina:  你看看普通的强爽算
Katrina: Check if there's a regular one, strong one counts too.
Katrina:  他们说强爽的比较劣质
Katrina: They say the strong one is of lower quality.
Shure:  来咱们39块钱今晚听个响
Shure: Let's spend 39 bucks and hear a pop tonight.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Yeah, I bought that 10 USB charger.
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: It was over 30 bucks each.
Jake: 响也没有就是一点都都充不上
Jake: No sound at all, it doesn't charge at all.
Jake: 看起来挺牛逼
Jake: Looks pretty cool though.
Alice: 起泡酒吗
Alice: Sparkling wine?
Shure:  对就可以蹦听个响
Shure: Yeah, we can party and hear a pop.
Jake: 这好歹能听个响
Jake: At least we can hear a pop.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我跟我朋友第一回开起泡酒的时候
Lucia: The first time my friend and I opened sparkling wine.
Lucia: 我们俩打开
Lucia: We opened it.
Lucia: 不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: Didn't know what to do next.
Lucia: 他就放在那
Lucia: So we just left it there.
Lucia: 就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: After a while, it popped, hahaha.
Jake: 哦延时崩
Jake: Oh, delayed pop.
Alice: 听个响
Alice: Just to hear a pop.
Jake: 延时听个响
Jake: Delayed pop sound.
Alice: 虎邦辣椒酱
Alice: HooBang Chili Sauce
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Anything else good?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about canned yellow peaches?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know it cures colds.
Alice: 哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Buy some snacks for that.
Lucia: 啊是真的可以治感冒吗
Lucia: Really, it can cure colds?
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  真的
Shure: It's true.
Katrina:  可以买什么
Katrina: What can we buy?
Shure:  在东北可以
Shure: In the northeast, it works.
Shure:  在别的地就不灵了
Shure: It doesn't work elsewhere.
Alice:不一定
Alice: Not necessarily.
Shure:  这个东西
Shure: This thing...
Katrina:  买什么
Katrina: Buy what?
Lucia: 有这样的吗
Lucia: Is there such a thing?
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha, it also cures colds.
Alice:黄桃罐头
Alice: Canned yellow peaches.
Katrina:  哦哦黄桃罐头
Katrina: Oh, canned yellow peaches.
Shure:  就是这个东西
Shure: That's the thing.
Jake: 拜菩萨也治感冒对
Jake: Praying to Buddha also cures colds, right?
Shure:  非非常的违心
Shure: Very superstitious.
Alice: 拜妈祖
Alice: Pray to Mazu.
Alice: 福建的管用
Alice: It works in Fujian.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  想买一包咪咪吃
Katrina: I want to buy a pack of Mimi to eat.
Katrina:  就当那个
Katrina: Just for that.
Katrina:  等早饭外卖
Katrina: While waiting for breakfast delivery.
Katrina:  的垫垫肚子那个
Katrina: To fill the stomach a bit.
Jake: 啊行行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  小零食可以
Shure: Snacks are fine.
Katrina:  对要是怕有的人胃不舒都行
Katrina: Yes, in case someone's stomach feels uncomfortable.
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Isn't that picnic snacks? Haha.
Alice: 周冬雨
Alice: Zhou Dongyu.
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What?
Alice: 什么玩意
Alice: What is it?
Tasha: 不再回家薄荷糖
Tasha: Don't go home again, mint candy.
Tasha: 哦结你
Tasha: Oh, Jie you.
Tasha: 你结过账了是吧
Tasha: You already paid, right?
Katrina:  我没有我买的是自己的东西
Katrina: No, I didn't. I bought my own stuff.
Katrina:  他们还没结呢
Katrina: They haven't paid yet.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So, we can exchange everything for Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Exchange it for new currency.
Alice: 这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: That way, it won't feel so painful, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛新
Jake: This is too outrageous, 50 cents new currency.
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents of new currency.
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: Is 3.9 just 50 cents?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 是6毛钱吧
Jake: It's 60 cents, right?
Jake: 是51:五点三吧现在得
Jake: It's 51:5.3 now, right?
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: You just divide by 5 and subtract 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: Roughly divide by 5.
Shure:  然后再减去抹个0就对了
Shure: Then subtract and round off, and you're good.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yeah, give me the new currency.
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  在7新币也就
Shure: It's about 7 new currency.
Jake: 七新币的酒
Jake: A 7 new currency drink.
Jake: 这听这这也听
Jake: Listen, this sounds...
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Can you hear the sound?
Jake: 1是米的球
Jake: 1 is the rice ball.
Lucia: 好像也还行
Lucia: Seems okay.
Lucia: 奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: Audi and Lidl have a lot of items at this price.
Lucia: 你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Audi and Lidl there?
Katrina:  欧了欧了
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 我们不怎么买不太懂
Jake: We don't really buy much, so we don't know.
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But 7 new currency sounds really cheap.
Alice: 这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand's small beer.
Shure:  懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: This is less than 1 new currency.
Lucia: 媒体小铺
Lucia: Media shop.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This bag of whatever.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, Body Shop is a British brand.
Alice: 嗯这边破产了
Alice: Hmm, it went bankrupt here.
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also got something for less than 20 cents new currency.
Alice: 清仓
Alice: Clearing out
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint candy
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on, we'll report everything in new currency to Jake
Lucia: 那我买了瓶饮料可以吗
Lucia: Is it okay if I buy a drink?
Lucia: 虽然我是自己喝
Lucia: Even though it's just for me
Lucia: 不过大概也就5毛星币吧
Lucia: It's probably only about 0.5 new currency
Tasha: 按5毛新币
Tasha: Count it as 0.5 new currency
Lucia: 5毛新币
Lucia: 0.5 new currency
Tasha: 新币的换算比例是
Tasha: The conversion rate for new currency is...
Shure:  嗯除以5再抹个0
Shure: Hmm, divide by 5 and round off
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: Tell him it's about 5.3
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag
Alice:这小的是啥啊
Alice: What's this small one?
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in new currency?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 units
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 units is less than 1 new currency
Tasha: 一个金币
Tasha: One gold coin
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not convert it yet, haha
Jake: 来来来
Jake: Come on, come on
Jake: 怎么付啊
Jake: How do we pay?
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag
Lucia: 这方法会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Wouldn't this method be a bit heavy?
Katrina:  party没关系
Katrina: It's okay for the party
Lucia: 哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you carry it then
Lucia: 那那就放了
Lucia: Alright, I'll put it in then
Lucia: 那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: I won't be polite then, haha
Katrina:  哈哈哈没事
Katrina: Haha, it's fine
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Shure:  友好小票子
Shure: Friendly small bill
Alice:你从这里回学校是得两个多小时两个半不到
Alice: It takes you over two hours, almost two and a half, to get back to school from here
其他人：对两个小时吧
Others: Yeah, about two hours
Katrina:  走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where's Hema?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get down to business
其他人：还要回别墅拿东西
Others: We still need to go back to the villa to get stuff
Jake: 可以哎我看看还能录多久啊
Jake: Okay, let me see how much longer we can record
其他人：嗯是
Others: Yeah, right
Alice: 啊一个小时
Alice: Ah, one hour.
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: Alright, that works.
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can you get the work done in an hour?
Alice:这谁啊
Alice: Who is this?
Alice:这是泽塔吗还是谁
Alice: Is this Zeta or someone else?
Alice: 赛罗对不起
Alice: Zoro, I'm sorry.
Alice: 我有罪
Alice: My bad.
Alice: 竟然没认出来他
Alice: I didn't recognize him.
Jake: 他当场切肉是吗
Jake: Did he cut the meat on the spot?
Shure:  不是我回去处理的时候
Shure: No, I handled it when I got back.
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You handled it when you got back?
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: After recharging, you started over?
Jake: 就重来了呀
Jake: Started over, huh?
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: It wasn't the same batch then.
Tasha: 哦我已经看到他了
Tasha: Oh, I already saw him.
Shure:  我也看到他了
Shure: I saw him too.
Shure:  我看到了他的倒影
Shure: I saw his reflection.
Alice:谁呀哦盒马
Alice: Who is it? Oh, Hema.
Shure:  在反转世界在镜花水月中
Shure: In the mirrored world, in the illusion.
Shure:  我已经看到了他
Shure: I already saw him.
Alice: 有一股生瓜子的味道
Alice: 炒瓜子啊
Alice: Roasted sunflower seeds?
Alice: 炒货
Alice: Roasted snacks.
Alice: 香的呛人
Alice: The smell is strong.
Alice: 哎呦炒货的味道好呛啊
Alice: Oh wow, the smell of roasted snacks is really strong.
Lucia: 哎咱是不是要推个车
Lucia: Hey, should we push a cart?
Lucia: 哦哦他们推了
Lucia: Oh, they already pushed one.
Tasha: 是不是要买很多羊肉粒牛肉粒
Tasha: Do we need to buy a lot of lamb cubes and beef cubes?
Lucia: 突然发现忘记推迟
Lucia: Suddenly realized we forgot to delay.
Alice: 他是不是还要买签儿啊
其他人：签谁买了呗你不说
Others: Who bought the skewer? You didn't say.
Lucia: 可能有一次性的那种竹签对
Lucia: Maybe it's the disposable bamboo skewers, right.
Alice:竹签吗
Alice: Bamboo skewers?
Alice: 应该有哪种直接带签的
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: Skewers, skewers, how to handle it?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: It just seems useless, you know?
Jake: 闲着用啊
Jake: Use it when idle.
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: What are you doing then?
Lucia: 这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are some already skewered and some skewers.
Alice:这不是有穿好的吗
Alice: Aren't there some already skewered?
Lucia: 所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All the problems are solved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: No, let's buy some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: The chicken wings I marinate are really delicious.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Alright, let's get some.
Katrina:  想要充分展示自己的能力
Katrina: I want to fully showcase my abilities.
Shure:  要拿吗也拿点这个
Shure: Should we grab some of this too?
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Yeah, grab some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: Okay, but we need to ensure we have enough food so we don't starve.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: Enough food.
Shure:  然后在在死之上
Shure: And then, on top of that...
Lucia: 啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Ah, are these lamb chops?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Oh wow, lamb chops.
Tasha: 一个新币
Tasha: One new dollar.
Tasha: 加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Together, that's two new dollars.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 10
Alice: 10.
Alice: 10点多
Alice: A bit past 10.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: Buying two new dollars in Singapore gets you half a skewer.
Lucia: 10新币
Lucia: 10 new dollars.
Shure:  五十九十新币
Shure: 50, 90 new dollars.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that, haha?
Lucia: 算成50:1了
Lucia: Calculated it as 50:1.
算成五十
Tasha: 这5:1吗 5:1
Tasha: Is it 5:1? 5:1?
Lucia: 哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Haha, about 5 and a bit.
Alice: 5点多
Alice: 5 and a bit.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yeah, about one skewer.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just one beef skewer.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: This kind of beef skewer.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: About this kind of skewer.
Jake: 一一新币一个哦
Jake: One new dollar each, oh.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: One new dollar per skewer.
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yeah, one new dollar each.
Jake: 位置好一点就两心闭一串
Jake: In a better location, it’s two dollars per skewer.
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, I don’t need these.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We don’t need these.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: These definitely don't taste good.
Katrina:  你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own secret marinade recipe?
Katrina:  还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yes, it’s been in my family for eighteen generations.
Katrina:  那那那买这种买这种
Katrina: Then, then, let's buy this one, buy this one.
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you buy the meat yet?
Jake: 还没开始呢
Jake: Not yet.
Lucia: 我也想知道
Lucia: I want to know too.
Lucia: 世界好店
Lucia: The best store in the world.
Lucia: 藤椒味的瓜子
Lucia: Sichuan pepper flavored sunflower seeds.
Shure:  那个很好吃
Shure: Those are really tasty.
Katrina:  之前藤椒冰淇淋呢
Katrina: What about the Sichuan pepper ice cream from before?
Lucia: 啊真的还有藤椒冰淇淋啊
Lucia: Oh really, there's Sichuan pepper ice cream too?
Alice:啥啊
Alice: What?
Shure:  巨好吃那个藤藤椒
Shure: That Sichuan pepper is super tasty.
Katrina:  麦当劳这边出在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had it as a limited edition in Sichuan.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Shure:  那个瓜子
Shure: The sunflower seeds.
Lucia: 麦当劳是有什
Lucia: McDonald's has what?
Lucia: 麦当劳你有什么心事吗
Lucia: McDonald's, do you have any concerns?
Jake: 藤椒瓜藤椒冰淇淋
Jake: Sichuan pepper sunflower seeds, Sichuan pepper ice cream.
Jake: 藤椒瓜子
Jake: Sichuan pepper sunflower seeds.
Katrina:  之前麦当劳出过在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had it as a limited edition in Sichuan before.
Jake: 藤椒冰淇淋我靠
Jake: Sichuan pepper ice cream, wow.
Katrina:  就是还浇那个辣子油
Katrina: They even poured chili oil on it.
Alice:我给你提着吧给我吧
Alice: Let me carry that for you, give it to me.
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 来放进去放进去
Jake: Come on, put it in, put it in.
Shure:  来我需要洋葱调料串
Shure: Come on, I need the onion seasoning skewer.
Jake: 串那个竹签怎么整
Jake: How do you skewer the bamboo sticks?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 竹签竹签儿
Jake: The bamboo sticks, the bamboo sticks.
Shure:  呃烤的那个
Shure: Uh, the grilled one.
Katrina:  他就直接烤肉了
Katrina: He just grills the meat directly.
Shure:  直接用这个
Shure: Just use this directly.
Shure:  然后不穿
Shure: And don't skewer it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  咱们就烤片
Shure: We'll just grill slices.
Shure:  然后腌好
Shure: Then marinate it.
Shure:  然后烤片可以吧
Shure: Then grill the slices, is that okay?
Jake: 行行行不要签了
Jake: Alright, alright, no need for sticks.
Alice: 有那个夹子吗 翻面的
Alice: Do we have tongs for flipping?
Shure:  啊对好问题
Shure: Ah, good question.
Shure:  咱们再补个夹子
Shure: Let's get another pair of tongs.
Alice: 沙子跟油
Alice: Sand and oil.
Shure:  好问题啊
Shure: Good question.
Shure:  油有刷子刷子也有刷刷子
Shure: Oil has a brush, and the brush has a brush too.
Alice: 孜然
Alice: Cumin.
Shure:  你那天哎那谁呢
Shure: That day, hey where is that person?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 就是公寓
Jake: It's in the apartment.
Jake: 在别墅里面有是吧
Jake: Inside the villa, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 别说有那夹子哈
Jake: Don't say there's a clip, huh?
Alice: 吃筷子也能
Alice: You can eat with chopsticks too.
Shure:  我为什么要拎着他呀我靠
Shure: Why am I carrying him? Oh, come on.
Shure:  才想起来
Shure: Just remembered.
Shure:  我还傻傻地拎着他
Shure: I was stupidly carrying him.
Shure:  这时候就应该向他问一个问题
Shure: This is the time to ask him a question.
Shure:  为什么我有一个车而不放进去
Shure: Why do I have a car but don't put it in?
Jake: 他花了多长时间意识到这个问题
Jake: How long did it take him to realize this?
Shure:  对他花了
Shure: Yeah, it took him...
Shure:  我花了多久意识到这个问题
Shure: How long did it take me to realize this?
Lucia: 啊这是什么
Lucia: Ah, what is this?
Jake: 啊啊确实很贵啊
Jake: Ah, it's really expensive.
Shure:  哎回去了
Shure: Oh, went back.
Shure:  没有看到鸡翅吗
Shure: Didn't you see the chicken wings?
Alice: 你得去那个生肉那边买
Alice: You have to go to the raw meat section to buy them.
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 所以我上次在上海的时候惊讶的发现
Lucia: So last time when I was in Shanghai, I was surprised to find out...
Lucia: 上海东西竟然没比英国便宜多少
Lucia: Things in Shanghai aren't much cheaper than in the UK.
Lucia: 也可能我老去立冬和奥迪a
Lucia: Maybe I always go to Lidl and Aldi.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 这段删掉
Lucia: Cut this part out.
Lucia: 听起来我生活的好好悲惨
Lucia: It makes my life sound so miserable.
Alice: 你好请问鸡翅在哪里
Alice: Excuse me, where are the chicken wings?
其他人：鲜鸡翅
Others: Fresh chicken wings.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
其他人：我不知道有没有了就那块走到头卖肉的那块
Others: I don't know if there are any left, just go to the end where they sell meat.
Alice: 修
Alice: Shure.
Alice: 开车走到头
Alice: Drive to the end.
Alice: 可能没有了
Alice: Maybe there's none left.
Alice: 可能有可能没有嗯
Alice: Maybe, maybe not, um.
Shure:  他说的我靠
Shure: He said, "Oh my god."
Alice: 闻到羊的味道
Alice: I can smell lamb.
Alice:这
Alice: This
Alice: 鸡中翅
Alice: Chicken wings.
Shure:  鸡翅中
Shure: Chicken wings.
Alice: 鸡中翅
Alice: Chicken wings.
Shure:  啊他为什么叫鸡中翅
Shure: Why do they call it chicken wings?
Alice: 不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Shure:  可以一盒够吗
Shure: Will one box be enough?
Shure:  咱们几个人
Shure: How many of us are there?
Shure:  一人两个差不多
Shure: Two each should be enough.
Alice: 13个差不多
Alice: 13 should be enough.
Shure:  啊还有一个学姐还有
Shure: Oh, there's also that senior and...
Alice: 你还要什么
Alice: What else do you want?
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then...
Alice: 五花肉要吗
Alice: Do we need pork belly?
Shure:  不要我拿着排骨了
Shure: No, I got ribs.
Alice: 嗯还有什么
Alice: Hmm, what else?
Alice: 那如果有那种一层一层的小饼也可以烤
Alice: If there are those layered pancakes, we can grill those too.
Alice: 一卷
Alice: One roll.
Shure:  啊淄博卷饼是吧
Shure: Ah, Zibo pancakes, right?
Alice: 生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Alice: 需要生菜吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Shure:  可以买点
Shure: We can buy some.
Shure:  买点生菜吧
Shure: Let's buy some lettuce.
Shure:  然后卷着吃
Shure: And then wrap it.
Alice: 这是腌奥尔良的吧应该
Alice: This should be marinated in Orleans-style, right?
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice: 哪种都行
Alice: Any kind is fine.
Shure:  选择相信我
Shure: Trust my choice.
Shure:  哈哈哈拿到了
Shure: Hahaha, got it.
Alice:OK
Alice: 拿到了
Alice: Got it.
Tasha: 安排
Tasha: Arrangements.
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Let's think, there are 7 of us.
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: 7 people eating, right?
Tasha: 那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we get that barbecue seasoning?
Tasha: 烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue seasoning.
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yes, let me calculate how much meat we need.
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs.
Lucia: 这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Tasha needs this for making dessert.
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Shure: Ah, then lend me two later.
Tasha: 不借哈哈哈哈
Tasha: No, haha.
Shure:  不借哈哈哈
Shure: No, haha.
Alice: 洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure:  要要腌的话会
Shure: If you want to marinate...
Tasha: 要腌东西要用嗯
Tasha: You need it for marinating, yeah.
Lucia: 我以为要往上面裹汁嘞
Lucia: I thought you were going to coat it with sauce.
Alice: 洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure:  对洋葱
Shure: Yes, onions.
Tasha: 洋葱在这里就有
Tasha: Onions are right here.
Shure:  我先算算一下肉的肉的量
Shure: Let me first calculate the amount of meat.
Alice: 在那呢
Alice: It's over there.
Alice: 但是他你要不
Alice: But if you...
Alice: 买那个洋葱吧
Alice: Buy that onion.
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure: I want red onions.
Shure:  紫皮洋葱
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: This one's really purple.
Lucia: 紫的这种的呗
Lucia: Yeah, the purple ones.
Jake: 这边啊
Jake: Over here.
Alice: 这个有机的
Alice: This one's organic.
Alice: 这个普通的
Alice: This one's regular.
Tasha: 没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: It's okay, let's just get the expensive one.
Lucia: 要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want the big one or the small one?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much for the organic?
Tasha: 我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think the smaller ones are better.
Tasha: 呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, three small ones would be good.
Tasha: 这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: This way, we won't waste any.
Lucia:400克 5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 400 grams for 5.9 bucks. This is the type...
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  一新币这个
Shure: This one's 1 dollar.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much for half a dollar?
Shure:  这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  4块3
Shure: 4.3 bucks.
Jake: 没差别
Jake: There's no difference.
Alice: 1不到1
Alice: Less than 1, almost 1.
Jake: 那没差别
Jake: Then there's no difference.
Jake: 有机
Jake: Organic.
Tasha: 没差别
Tasha: No difference.
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, it's just a dollar difference.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: Ah, but this is 100 grams lighter than that.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: That's enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话一斤一斤半
Shure: Then for the meat, one to one and a half pounds.
Alice: 需要土豆什么吗
Alice: Do we need potatoes or anything?
Alice: 土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes, lettuce.
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And those skewers below.
Alice: 生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Shure:  然后也也有肉是不
Shure: And there's meat too, right?
Shure:  这是多少斤
Shure: How many pounds is this?
Shure:  300克才 300克量
Shure: Only 300 grams, it's just 300 grams.
Alice: 生菜需要吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Shure:  需要拿点生菜
Shure: Yes, get some lettuce.
Alice: 生菜在那呢
Alice: The lettuce is over there.
Alice: 哎刚刚不是还见到的吗
Alice: Hey, didn't we just see it?
Jake: 呃哪一个小时用来给我传数据了
Jake: Uh, which hour was used to send me the data?
Shure:  立即传
Shure: Sending it now.
Lucia: 刚回去的那个小时吧
Lucia: The hour just after we got back.
Jake: 立即传啊
Jake: Send it now, huh?
Shure:  对然后因为我们要处理这些的
Shure: Yes, because we need to handle these.
Shure:  就也要也要拍一下了是吧
Shure: We need to take a picture too, right?
Jake: OK那对对是的
Jake: Okay, yes, yes.
Jake: 所以回去之后先放冰箱就给我传是吗
Jake: So, after we get back, first put it in the fridge then send it to me, right?
Jake: 要放冰箱吗
Jake: Do we need to put it in the fridge?
Shure:  对也其实也
Shure: Yes, actually, yes.
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, we do.
Lucia: 放冰箱要拍吗
Lucia: Do we need to take a picture before putting it in the fridge?
Jake: 要拍放一下吧放一下吧
Jake: Yes, take a picture, then put it in.
Lucia: 要拍那就放啊
Lucia: Take a picture, then put it in.
Alice:放一下吧
Alice: Put it in for a bit.
Alice:冷藏一下
Alice: Refrigerate it for a while.
Jake: 放下等着然后开始切是吧
Jake: Put it down, wait, and then start cutting, right?
Shure:  咱们7个人吧不是
Shure: There are seven of us, right?
Shure:  没有主食
Shure: No staple food.
Shure:  对不吃主食
Shure: Yeah, no staple food.
Lucia: 不是土土土豆
Lucia: But, potatoes, potatoes.
Alice:土豆
Alice: Potatoes.
Jake: 有有土豆
Jake: We have potatoes.
Lucia: 那土豆也算是一种主食
Lucia: Well, potatoes count as a staple food too.
Lucia: 因为主要主要成分是淀粉对吧
Lucia: Because their main component is starch, right?
Alice:土豆三个够吗
Alice: Are three potatoes enough?
其他人：面包片要烤吗
Others: Should we toast some bread?
Lucia: 强词夺利
Lucia: Forceful argument
Shure:  可以烤点面包片
Shure: We can toast some bread.
Shure:  对来来点面包片吧
Shure: Yes, let's toast some bread.
其他人：对我吃烧烤就想吃面包片
Others: Yeah, I crave bread with barbecue.
Jake: 面包片做早饭是吧
Jake: Bread for breakfast, right?
Jake: 明明天做个早饭吧
Jake: Let's make breakfast tomorrow.
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, alright.
Jake: 哈哈哈现在点菜
Jake: Haha, now let's order.
Jake: 其实点菜还要吃什么烧烤
Jake: Actually, why order food if we're having barbecue?
Katrina:  有水果吗
Katrina: Do we have any fruit?
Katrina:  我们水果吃完了好像都
Katrina: Seems like we've eaten all the fruit.
Alice:没有
Alice: No, we don't.
Katrina:  再买一个
Katrina: Let's buy some more.
Lucia: 那我们要不买买点什么水果好啊
Lucia: How about we buy some fruit?
Katrina:  买点好剥的
Katrina: Let's get something easy to peel.
Katrina:  橘子还有那个阳光玫瑰那个
Katrina: Like oranges or those Sunshine Roses.
Lucia: 哎我们之前是买了一颗蓝莓
Lucia: Oh, we bought some blueberries before.
Lucia: 还在冰箱里
Lucia: They're still in the fridge.
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes, they are.
Lucia: 那今天得把它吃掉
Lucia: We should eat them today.
Lucia: 不然容易坏
Lucia: Or they'll go bad.
Katrina:  啊好
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 然后我们再补充一点水果
Lucia: Then we can get some more fruit.
Shure:  好够了肯定够了
Shure: That'll be enough, definitely enough.
Katrina:  草莓呢也得吃
Katrina: We should eat the strawberries too.
Katrina:  是不是还有一盒
Katrina: Isn't there another box?
Alice: 草莓有一盒那个要干嘛
Alice: There's one box of strawberries. What do you want to do with them?
Alice:做做做
Alice: Just do it.
Katrina:  要不要来一箱北冰洋
Katrina: Should we get a case of Arctic Ocean?
Katrina:  北冰洋要配烤肉
Katrina: Arctic Ocean goes well with barbecue.
Katrina:  我们小孩吃
Katrina: Our kids can drink it.
Alice:走
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  我还没到呢
Shure: I haven't arrived yet.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know what?
Shure:  我那天还试了一下
Shure: I tried it the other day.
Katrina:  你是去民政局了
Katrina: Did you go to the Civil Affairs Bureau?
Shure:  不我是民政局预约不行
Shure: No, I couldn't get an appointment at the Civil Affairs Bureau.
Katrina:  哎呀我去拿水果去
Katrina: Oh, I'm going to get some fruit.
Lucia: 啊河马
Lucia: Ah, hippo.
Shure:  然后去买调料
Shure: Then let's go buy some seasonings.
Shure:  调料在那
Shure: The seasonings are over there.
Shure:  有大瓶的
Shure: There's a big bottle.
Shure:  全是咱们用不了这么多
Shure: It's all too much for us to use.
Shure:  怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do?
Lucia: 烤味呃
Lucia: Grilled flavor, uh...
Lucia: 烧烤汁吗
Lucia: Barbecue sauce?
Shure:  不是需要料酒
Shure: No, we need cooking wine.
Alice: 放料酒吗
Alice: Should we add cooking wine?
Shure:  不然的话鸡翅会很腥
Shure: Otherwise, the chicken wings will taste fishy.
Alice: 洋葱
Alice: Onion.
Shure:  九块九六块九的
Shure: Nine ninety, six ninety.
Shure:  哎一新币两新币
Shure: Hey, one dollar, two dollars.
Shure:  这太大了这也
Shure: This is too big, it’s...
Shure:  吃不了就浪费了
Shure: If we can’t finish it, it’ll be wasted.
Shure:  有小的吗
Shure: Are there smaller ones?
Shure:  你好这些有小的吗
Shure: Hi, do you have smaller ones of these?
Shure:  啊不好意思不好意思不好意思
Shure: Ah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Alice: 这种的多少钱你看
Alice: How much is this type? Look.
Lucia: 但那个反而其实要比这个贵嘞
Lucia: But that one is actually more expensive.
Alice:对只是
Alice: Yeah, just...
Lucia: 但是体感上我们浪费的少了一些
Lucia: But it feels like we waste less.
Lucia: 或者如能不能用酱油代替蚝油
Lucia: Or, can we use soy sauce instead of oyster sauce?
Lucia: 房房间里有酱油吗
Lucia: Is there soy sauce in the room?
Alice:蚝油你要用来腌啥
Alice: What are you going to marinate with oyster sauce?
Shure:  也是腌肉
Shure: Also for marinating meat.
Alice: 白糖我没有白糖
Alice: I don't have white sugar.
Shure:  你说白糖还要要一瓶
Shure: You said we need a bottle of white sugar.
Shure:  一定要一瓶百事可乐
Shure: We definitely need a bottle of Pepsi.
Shure:  因为可口没有那么甜
Shure: Because Coke isn't as sweet.
Shure:  哎那有那有蚝油啊
Shure: Hey, there's oyster sauce over there!
Alice: 要更贵
Alice: It's more expensive.
Lucia: 但是它其实更贵
Lucia: But it's actually more expensive.
Shure:  我们是以着不浪费的原则
Shure: Are we trying to avoid waste or save money?
Shure:  还是以更贵的原则
Shure: Or go for the more expensive option?
Lucia: 嗯看你是指资源还是金钱的浪费了
Lucia: Hmm, depends on whether you're talking about wasting resources or money.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  我是指资源
Shure: I mean resources.
Alice: 我们过几天会有什么饭需要做吗
Alice: Do we have any meals we need to cook in the next few days?
Alice: 不会吧
Lucia: 做饭感觉主要只是为了采集一下
Lucia: Cooking feels like it's mainly for gathering purposes.
Lucia: 人类活动而已
Lucia: Just a human activity.
Shure:  这玩意够用一个月的了都
Shure: This stuff is enough for a whole month.
Alice: 耗油很省的
Shure:  对啊来来这个吧来这个
Shure: Yeah, come on, let's use this.
Shure:  然后别别浪费粮食
Shure: And don't waste food.
Shure:  浪费粮食
Shure: Don't waste food.
Alice: 蘸料
Alice: Dipping sauce.
Shure:  这都是腌咸的
Shure: This is all salted.
Shure:  就不用蘸料了
Shure: No need for dipping sauce.
Alice: 不用摘啊
Alice: No need to pick it off?
Alice: 那孜然呢
Alice: What about cumin?
Shure:  孜然那些调料是要用的
Shure: Cumin and those spices are necessary.
Shure:  再找一下这边
Shure: Let's look around here.
Alice: 六婆直接六婆吧
Alice: Let's just go with Liupo.
Shure:  六婆是什么
Shure: What's Liupo?
Alice: 六婆辣椒面
Alice: Liupo chili powder.
Shure:  我靠没听过这个
Shure: Wow, never heard of that.
Alice: 六婆这么有名的蘸料
Alice: Liupo is such a famous dipping sauce.
Shure:  真没清过
Shure: Really never heard of it.
Shure:  盐咱们有是吧
Shure: We have salt, right?
Alice: 有
Alice: Yes.
Shure:  有
Shure: Good.
Alice: 糖也有
Alice: We also have sugar.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Katrina:  笑什么
Katrina: What's so funny?
Lucia: 是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 yuan king crab from the other day?
Lucia: 还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Alice:还有醋
Alice: We also have vinegar.
Jake: 波龙还是波龙不应该这么贵
Jake: Boston lobsters shouldn't be this expensive.
Lucia: 哎我也想说
Lucia: Yeah, I was going to say.
Lucia: 其实波龙在国内还挺贵的
Lucia: Actually, Boston lobsters are quite expensive domestically.
Jake: 波龙在波士顿就十十美元
Jake: In Boston, they're just ten dollars each.
Jake: 10美元一只
Jake: 10 dollars each.
Lucia: 哦那比在比在伦敦还便宜
Lucia: Oh, that's even cheaper than in London.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 当时吃了一周就天天的买
Jake: We ate them for a whole week, buying them every day.
Jake: 然后吃腻了
Jake: Then we got tired of them.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 听起来很爽的亚子
Lucia: Sounds awesome
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Lucia: 伦敦大概15磅
Lucia: Around 15 pounds in London
Alice: 扔这里面呗
Alice: Throw it in here
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 啊我喜欢这个
Lucia: Ah, I like this
Alice: 山竹
Alice: Mangosteen
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else do we need?
Jake: 明早让他们做个早饭
Jake: Tomorrow morning, let them make breakfast
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake: 啊明早会做
Jake: Ah, they'll make it tomorrow morning
Jake: 明天明早做早饭吧
Jake: Make breakfast tomorrow morning
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure
Lucia: 可以做我们刚才是不是买了面包
Lucia: Can we make it? Didn't we just buy bread?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 还是怎么回事来着
Lucia: Or what happened?
Alice: 面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet
Katrina:  买个面包搞点番茄酱就行了
Katrina: Just buy some bread and get some ketchup
Tasha: 后再买点生菜
Tasha: Then buy some lettuce
Tasha: 直接做个三明治
Tasha: Just make a sandwich
Alice: 刚才有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We had some earlier, but not sure if it's enough
Katrina:  hamburger选手在
Katrina: The hamburger expert is here
Jake: 明天就在
Jake: It'll be here tomorrow
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: Just stay inside
Katrina:  对呀
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Dance or something
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the delivery arrives, sort it out
Katrina:  对明天主要快递会很多
Katrina: Yeah, there'll be a lot of deliveries tomorrow
Lucia: 到这个我的快递为什么还没到
Lucia: Why hasn't my delivery arrived yet?
Alice: 对，他发货没有啊
Lucia: 我在京东上买的东西
Lucia: I bought it on JD
Lucia: 应该今天到啊
Lucia: It should arrive today
Jake: 好行行好的
Jake: Okay, alright, alright
其他人：那我自己先走了
Others: Then I'll go by myself first
Jake: 好可以好
Jake: Alright, that's fine
Katrina:  你要回去啊
Katrina: Are you going back?
其他人：我要赶紧回别墅拿东西
Others: I need to rush back to the villa to get something
Katrina:  打卡吗
Katrina: Clocking in?
Katrina:  啊那你好折腾
Katrina: Ah, you're such a troublemaker.
Katrina:  拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye bye, bye bye.
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you on Sunday, you'll come on Sunday, right?
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So, there are six of us?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: It's okay, we won't be able to finish it.
Shure:  周日再弄吧
Shure: Let's deal with it on Sunday.
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Right, that works.
Shure:  没事了没事
Shure: It's fine now, no worries.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye.
Katrina:  拜拜
Katrina: Bye.
Shure:  哇你还买冰淇淋了
Shure: Wow, you even bought ice cream.
Lucia: 呃在配送途中
Lucia: Uh, on the way for delivery.
Katrina:  这是孜然啊
Katrina: Is this cumin?
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Alice: 我们还有白胡椒
Alice: We also have white pepper.
Lucia: 我喜欢这个
Lucia: I like this one.
Alice: 这是啥辣椒粉辣椒面
Alice: What kind of chili powder is this?
Katrina:  买面包了吗
Katrina: Did you buy bread?
Katrina:  没有是吧
Katrina: No, right?
Alice: 还没买面包呢
Alice: Haven't bought bread yet.
Shure:  行那再买点面面包
Shure: Alright, let's buy some bread then.
Katrina:  买个面包个番茄酱
Katrina: Buy some bread and ketchup.
Shure:  然后剩下的没有了就外卖一下吧
Shure: And if there's anything left, let's just order takeout.
Shure:  有上次有一个什么烘焙的那地方
Shure: Last time there was some baking place.
Lucia: 这里没有
Lucia: Not here.
Lucia: 那天那个帝王蟹耶
Lucia: That day, there was king crab.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈建立不了关联
Jake: Hahaha, can't establish a connection.
Jake: 关联建立失败
Jake: Connection failed.
Katrina:  哎这是吃饭点
Katrina: Hey, it's mealtime.
Katrina:  人家烘焙区呢
Katrina: Where's the baking section?
Katrina:  上次来的盒马没有这种店哎
Katrina: Last time at Hema, there wasn't a store like this.
Alice:这应该不是
Alice: This probably isn't it.
Alice:啊，是的
Lucia: 试一下建立别的关联
Lucia: Try to establish another connection.
Lucia: 那天还看到什么了
Lucia: What else did you see that day?
Alice: 啊这个是吗
Alice: Ah, is this it?
Alice: 面食之类的不知道好像不是那种
Alice: I don't know, it seems like it's not that kind of noodle.
Katrina:  哎也可以蒸玉米哈
Katrina: Oh, we can also steam corn.
Katrina:  玉米是不是得往锅里蒸啊
Katrina: Should we steam the corn in the pot?
Katrina:  不能放微波炉吧
Katrina: We can't use the microwave, right?
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Alice: 但我们有锅
Alice: But we have a pot.
Katrina:  哎烘焙区呢
Katrina: Hey, where's the baking area?
Shure:  其实我们还可以弄点什么花蛤啥的
Shure: Actually, we could also make some clams or something.
Shure:  烤一下哦
Shure: Just grill them.
Shure:  最重要的碳
Shure: The most important thing is the charcoal.
Shure:  对一会回去的路上咱们先把碳点着
Shure: Yeah, on our way back, we should light the charcoal first.
Shure:  然后分两
Shure: Then split it into two.
Katrina:  有点碳的东西吗
Katrina: Do we have anything with charcoal?
Katrina:  火打火
Katrina: Fire, light the fire.
Shure:  火火机咱们有吗
Shure: Do we have a lighter?
Alice: 火枪
Alice: A blowtorch.
Alice: 没有
Alice: We don't have one.
Alice: 一般卖碳的地方是不是会有那个啊
Alice: Don't places that sell charcoal usually have those?
Shure:  看的地方有
Shure: Some places do.
Katrina:  刷油的刷子和油有吗
Katrina: Do we have a brush and oil for brushing?
Alice: 我们
Alice: We...
Alice: 我们用纸箱动的话可以用它引火
Alice: If we use a cardboard box, we can use it to start the fire.
Alice: 只要有个打火机就行了
Alice: As long as we have a lighter, it's fine.
Shure:  也可以
Shure: That works too.
Alice: 火枪里面也可以不用
Alice: We don't necessarily need a blowtorch.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  刚刚那会好像你们你们先往那边走
Shure: Just now, it seemed like you all were heading that way.
Alice: 你想要酸奶吗
Alice: Do you want yogurt?
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Alice:我想找一个无糖的
Alice: I want to find a sugar-free one.
Katrina:  可以搞这种小瓶酸奶放冰箱里
Katrina: We could get these small bottles of yogurt for the fridge.
Katrina:  大家想喝就喝
Katrina: Anyone can drink them whenever.
Jake: 这哪家呀
Jake: Which brand is this?
Lucia: 我是一个都可以的树懒
Lucia: I'm a sloth who's okay with anything.
Lucia: 小瓶那像这种
Lucia: Small bottles like these.
Lucia: 然后可以分装
Lucia: Then we can portion them out.
Katrina:  孩子买的小小装的
Katrina: The ones kids buy are in small packs.
Jake: 他那个长的是这个
Jake: That one, what brand is it?
Jake: 玩是什么牌子呀
Jake: What brand is that?
Tasha: 嗯好的好的
Tasha: Hmm, okay, okay.
Katrina:  下面这个吗
Katrina: This one below?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
其他人：对拌坚果吃的
Others: Yes, you mix it with nuts.
Jake: 叫叫啥
Jake: What's it called?
其他人：原价卖39块9的
Others: Originally, it's sold for 39.9.
Jake: 有牌子吗
Jake: Is there a brand?
其他人：现在22块9促销的
Others: Now it's on sale for 22.9.
Jake: 我靠认不得
Jake: I can't recognize it.
Katrina:  这这3个
Katrina: These three.
Katrina:  3个太不划算了吧
Katrina: Three is not worth it, right?
Katrina:  我建议是拿这种小小的
Katrina: I suggest getting these small ones.
Katrina:  我们想喝就喝那种
Katrina: We can drink it whenever we want.
Alice:都可以我想看一下这个
Alice: All good, I just want to check this one.
Katrina:  这个两组19块9
Katrina: This one is two sets for 19.9.
Katrina:  啥意思啊
Katrina: What does that mean?
Katrina:  啊就是这这19块9
Katrina: Oh, it means this is 19.9.